je découvre des personnes qui font des
choses vraiment hyper étranges et il le
met en boucle en boucle pendant des
heures le moment est long je pense que
le monde est divisé en deux si on peut
parler de choses très sérieuses
[Musique]
ça va et toi ravi d'être ici j'allais
dire de te recevoir mais je suis pas du
tout chez moi mais plutôt chez toi ce
soir un petit peu on est au zénith de
Lille ici tu joues dans quelques heures
ta deuxième date ici alors le principe
est très simple tu vas avoir une une
roue d'emoji qui va s'afficher ok quand
tu es prête je t'invite à appuyer sur le
buzzer
très bien alors ça s'arrête sur un dé un
D on va voir ce qui se cache derrière
que se cache-t-il c'est un tu préfères
Orelsan ou damso tu as eu l'occasion de
faire des feat avec les deux alors damso
ça fait déjà quelques temps mais tu en
as refait un avec des monts récemment
Orelsan avec évidemment là aussi je
crois que c'est vraiment deux histoires
différentes bah pour commencer par damso
c'est une histoire qui date quoi ça
c'est je l'ai rencontré en 2017 dans une
salle qui s'appelle la Madeleine à
Bruxelles on est en train de répéter ça
tourne à lui moi je venais pour
l'accompagner au piano et pour faire
cette première partie
ce qui a été l'expérience la plus
enrichissante et intense de ma vie
encore jusqu'à aujourd'hui en fait on
crée de la cohérence en allant se
confronter à notre public et c'est ce
qui a créé à la fois un lien hyper fort
avec damso parce qu'on est devenu amis
parce qu'il m'a soutenu parce que il y
avait une sorte de protection de sa part
de bienveillance à mon égard et en même
temps une envie de continuer cette
histoire et puis que et puis voilà il
m'a d'abord invité sur son album avec le
morceau silence
et ça ça a été c'était rigolo je m'en
souviens très bien parce que c'était
impressionnant pour moi on peut comparer
silence et évidemment dans la façon dont
c'est arrivé en studio déjà ce que
c'était au même endroit au même studio
j'y pense Alice TP donc un studio à
Bruxelles et en fait dans les deux
casques qui s'est passé c'est que je
suis arrivé en studio en mode vas-y on
fait un truc
damso m'avait appelé pareil Orelsan et
et on essaie plein de trucs on avait
plein de prod de côté des
justement c'était un peu démon
différents mais c'est vrai que dans le
cas de évidemment et silence c'était
plus genre on arrive en studio et moi je
leur fais écouter des trucs on se fait
écouter des trucs on essaye il y a rien
qui vient et puis les heures passent et
donc on se démotivait un peu on sait pas
où on va et tout parfois c'est pas ça
tombe pas comme ça et puis sur mon petit
ordinateur et en fait je découvre que
j'ai des trucs j'ai toujours des trucs
de côté et pour des mots j'avais
enregistré un truc dans le métro en mode
un bruit de métro m'avait fait penser un
truc que c'était
noté le truc je crois que j'ai un truc
et tout et je fais un truc à l'arrache
mais vraiment sur mon ordi je mets une
sorte de petite réverbes un petit chorus
mais vraiment un truc de gros mytho et
je lui fais écouter et lui il fait OK et
il le met en boucle en boucle pendant
des heures le moment est long et moi je
suis là à côté moi je suis pas quelqu'un
qui a trop confiance en moi mais s'il y
a bien un truc dans lequel je crois
c'est le fait que je sais faire de la
musique et je crois au moins là-dedans
je me sens à ma place donc on trancher
entre les deux
intéressantes pour toi je crois qu'il y
en a un petit dernier dans le tu
préfères
oula c'est peut-être plus facile à
peut-être trancher d'ailleurs je sais
pas
non mais je peux pas trancher enfin si
oui et non je peux pas trancher entre
mon pays et le pays qui a permis aussi
que j'en sois là donc c'est ces deux
choses différentes en fait j'ai toujours
vécu à Bruxelles mais bon dans ma
tournée quand on est quatre soirs par
semaine pas chez soi on peut pas
vraiment dire qu'on vit chez soi donc
j'ai plutôt vécu dans un tourbus en fait
j'ai une vraie histoire aussi d'amour
avec la France parce que ça reste un
pays qui est beaucoup plus grand en
taille que la Belgique et malgré tout il
y a du public qui m'écoute jusqu'à
jusque dans le sud de la France donc
j'ai une un vrai attachement aussi bah à
mon public francophone donc en grande
partie français mais c'est aussi une
question que je me posais parce que la
Belgique c'est 11 millions d'habitants
dans ces eaux là la France c'est 67 68
millions est-ce que tu as l'impression
quand tu es un artiste en Belgique le
fait de s'exporter en France c'est un
objectif pour
[Musique]
c'est un cadeau en général c'est une
question qui vient de quelqu’un d’autre
la présidentielle c'était les candidats
qui se posaient des questions entre eux
t'inquiète t'as pas de question d'un
candidat à la présidentielle ce sera
quelqu'un d'autre on va le découvrir
ensemble ok salut Angel c'est Pierre que
tu m'as pas reconnu ce serait étrange et
qui voudrait dire que tu as fait un AVC
ce que je ne te souhaite pas par
ailleurs
je j'ai une petite question à te poser
c'est juste est-ce que tu peux parler à
Hugo de notre passion commune pour
je pense que tu vois de quoi je parle
sachant quand on s'est rencontré avec
Angèle très vite on sait parler de ça
premier degré genre je pense que le
monde est divisé en deux si on peut
parler de choses très sérieuse les gens
qui aiment la SMR Pierre et moi en
faisant partie et puis les gens
à qui ça met mal à l'aise et en fait moi
j'ai une petite résistance au début
c'était d'ailleurs on tournait
je suis tombée par hasard je connaissais
pas la SMR c'était à 3-4 ans et j'étais
un tourbus en un seul mini je tapais
tout ce que je voulais sur Youtube genre
aidez-moi à dormir et tout et je vois
asmr par tout ce qui est pas puis au
bout d'un moment je clique je découvre
des personnes qui font des choses
vraiment hyper étranges et tout avec des
ustensiles et des bruits et au début je
suis en mode qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
je vois ça à des potes et tout qui me
disent bah évidemment
où on gère
et donc je me suis pris une petite
passion genre un peu moquerie quoi genre
c'est trop bizarre mais petit à petit
j'ai commencé à kiffer j'ai surtout
compris qu'il fallait mettre ses
écouteurs et tout et c'est devenu une
petite passion et quand j'en ai parlé
avec Pierre sur le tournage de balance
ton quoi ce qui m'a fait le nerf de
venir jouer dans le clip on a beaucoup
rigolé parce qu'en fait il nous a
raconté des petites anecdotes ou lui en
fait avait découvert l'ASMR très jeune
et ça je lui laisserai un jour répondre
à cette question
et du coup je me souviens qu'on a bien
rigolé parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
que en fait ça nous ça crée un truc
a préparé
un blind test en asmr ok on va écouter
des musiques qu'ils ont fait alors je
sais pas comment j'ai pas écouté donc
des musiques on va essayer de deviner la
musique sachant que la musique sur ton
asmr trop bien je sais pas à quoi
m'attendre
mon équipe
fous ta cagoule bien entendu Fatal
Bazooka
c'est effectivement
dans une salle dans un zen mais parfois
je le fais des petites blagues de la SMR
que tout celles qui sont dans la vague
que ceux qui sont assis se lèchent ils
vont pas allez maintenant on y va ces
soirées-là avant même qu'elle sait
commencer déjà dans l'ambiance ça
fonctionne bien puis c'est vraiment
agréable à écouter franchement ça me met
pas du tout mal à l'aise ça crée pas du
tout hein
sur le désert
on va voir sur quoi ça s'arrête
alors c'est une bulle en général c'est
une citation qui est derrière
j'ai eu un article pas très cool
j'aimerais bien pouvoir l'oublier c'est
ma foutu tellement les boules je veux
pas lire jusqu'au bout on est dans la
merde jusqu'au cou c'est fou comme on a
su oublier le déni c'est tellement plus
cool que ce genre de vérité qui a dit ça
c'est moi qui ai dit ça je pense en 2019
exactement
42 degrés j'étais à Paris entre deux
dates et je me souviens avoir vraiment
vécu une sorte de moment de
apocalyptique quoi au tout était fermé
et il faisait une chaleur vraiment
impressionnante et du coup j'avais fait
cette petite chanson parce que
en 2019 c'était pas si longtemps mais je
me souviens qu'il y avait vraiment cette
histoire de déni qui aujourd'hui je
pense est de moins en moins là je crois
que
c'est toujours une angoisse et c'est
toujours aussi alarmant
cette forme d'angoisse ou est-ce que
c'est de la je pense qu'on leur tous et
toutes quand on a l'âge qu'on a je pense
que
c'est une peur que j'ai comme vraiment
tous mes amis de mon âge et de ma
génération c'est des questions que je me
pose même jusqu'à me dire bah ce que
j'ai envie d'avoir des enfants de là de
mon envie personnelle et de mon instinct
et tout ça d'avoir d'être parents j'ai
une sorte de crainte de lui laisser un
monde pourri et et voilà parfois je suis
prise d'angoisse comme tout le monde
parce que c'est angoissant et je pense
que en 2019 comme c'était avant le covid
le déni il était il était plus facile
parce que je crois que on sentait
peut-être plus puissant je crois que le
covid quand même a permis de nous mettre
une petite une petite pression en mode
en fait peut-être qu'on est pas si
on est peut-être vulnérable on est
peut-être pas si puissant que ça et donc
voilà ça reste une question et cette
vidéo
je pourrais toujours la chanter parce
que j'y crois toujours c'est vrai quand
je lis des articles alarmants c'est rare
que que j'ai le courage d'aller jusqu'au
bout et il y a plein de gens qui sont
dans le déni et pas mal de potes qui
sont artistes ou youtubeurs ou autre et
souvent il y a une forme de
schizophrénie c'est pas le bon terme
mais une forme de d'un côté tu as envie
de faire des choses tu as envie de
porter ta voix sur un sujet d'un autre
côté tu es consciente que toi-même tu as
un impact sur l'environnement qui est
négatif toi dans le cas d'artiste c'est
forcément le fait de faire des tournées
machin dans mon cas c'est le fait de
prendre l'avion très souvent pour faire
des reportages ou des choses toi tu sens
cette sorte de
c'est un paradoxe que je partage avec
beaucoup d'autres artistes et d'autres
personnes même médiatisées ou influentes
et je pense que c'est toujours le
l'équilibre et c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de trouver un équilibre entre
avoir envie de parler de quelque chose
d'important comme moi j'ai toujours fait
j'ai toujours essayé d'utiliser ma voix
pour
pour vous dire parler de sujets et
venir ajouter un peu
de la lumière sur un sujet que j'estime
important mais le climat ça reste une
question parce que c'est ce côté
d'urgence et ce côté aussi
oui ce côté qui nous concerne en fait
tous quoi et donc oui je rejoins ce truc
là de d'essayer de minimiser au maximum
mon impact mais mais en même temps qui
suis-je pour dire aux gens faites
attention à votre consommation quand je
fais des concerts 3-4 fois par semaine
avec des gens qui se déplacent
certainement en voiture et et ça c'est
un exemple parmi d'autres donc j'ai
conscience que forcément mon impact il
est important et en même temps là-dessus
pour te pour te rassurer je pense pas
que tu as besoin d'être rassuré mais
j'en parlais justement avec pas mal de
personnes qui sont engagées sur ce sujet
qui disaient mais oui personne n'est
parfait mais personne ne peut l'être et
c'est tant mieux déjà justement que des
personnes qui ont une audience qui ont
qui sont quand même visibles puissant
parler évidemment personne n'est parfait
mais c'est déjà quelque chose comme ça
intéressant on va passer à la question
suivante
de relance du coup la roue je t'invite à
appuyer quand tu veux on va voir sur
quel emoji ça s'arrête c'est un bonus je
sais pas on va voir ce qu'il y a
derrière
c'est un Patrick c'est un certain
Patrick tu es une chanson qui s'appelle
Patrick qui s'appelle dans la réédition
elle raconte l'histoire d'un mec qui
s'appelle Patrick qui globalement
insultes des gens sur internet je crois
pas aux changements climatique par
exemple toutes sortes de choses en ligne
c'est un mec super quoi
ça va comment tu as eu l'idée déjà de
faire un morceau sur un profil comme ça
ça fait longtemps que j'avais envie
d'écrire là-dessus ça fait longtemps que
j'avais envie de
d'essayer en fait plutôt que de dénoncer
un peu en mode premier degré le
harcèlement en ligne la désinformation
aussi des réseaux sociaux j'avais envie
de d'imaginer un personnage et de
presque m'approcher très proche de lui
et un peu essayer de l'observer et donc
je suis parti un peu de d'une idée que
forcément derrière chaque tweet il y a
un être humain qui a un cœur qui bat et
qui forcément a un cerveau mais que
peut-être n'utilise pas assez au moment
où il fait le tweet tu dis il est même
pas si mauvais dans sa dans la vraie vie
ou dans sa vraie vie
il y a le côté le personnage en ligne
peut-être anonyme d'ailleurs qui dévers
son truc et la personne dans la vraie
vie qui a des défauts mais qui est
peut-être pas comme on pourrait
l'imaginer comment tu expliques ce
décalage potentiel entre
c'est pour ça Patrick en fait parce que
c'est un nom un peu plus commun et
j'avais envie de vraiment imaginer que
derrière Patrick il pourrait y avoir
n'importe qui en fait le prénom Patrick
c'est aussi parce que moi j'ai eu un
petit
Patrick et il m'a vraiment fait un joli
message d'insultes et tout merveilleux
sur Twitter et c'était comme ça que le
mot Patrick m'est venu mais finalement
c'est pas tellement moi dont je parle
dans cette chanson c'est aussi de me
dire bah je suis sûr que ce mec là c'est
pas genre si on se croise dans la rue il
va pas me dire ce qui m'a dit je vais
pas vous dire le tweet parce que ce
serait vraiment moche mais il y avait
beaucoup d'insultes en même temps
je suis persuadé que je croisais ce
monsieur dans la rue ils se mettrait pas
à m'insulter de la même manière ce qui
veut dire que il est bon je sais pas
mais ça veut dire qu'en tout cas pas
aussi mauvais quoi je suis sûr que ce
monsieur là il peut même faire un petit
sourire quand il fait ses courses ou et
aider peut-être un passement traverser
de voir quelqu'un et c'était important
aussi pour moi de désacraliser justement
les haters de pas voir ça comme une
sorte de masse de foule flippant de gens
qui sont là qui veulent ta mort mais
plutôt de gens qui sont peut-être perdus
qui ont peut-être besoin d'attirer
l'attention qui ont peut-être besoin
d'exister et qui se rendent pas non plus
compte que la succession de mots qui
mettent et qui font une phrase et qui et
qui rentre quelque chose de de blessant
pour la personne qui le reçoit en fait
c'est réel je pense que tout devient
irréel et
en vrai j'ai trouvé ça très fort
justement pour personnifier le truc et
ça m'a rappelé d'ailleurs au passage
ce qui avait pu faire damso justement ce
qu'on parlait vite tout à l'heure sur
alors rien à voir ce que le sujet n'est
absolument pas le même mais dans Julien
qu'il avait sorti il y a quelques années
c'était une thématique qu'il avait
abordé très dure une thématique très
grave parce que c'était la question de
la pédophilie mais à travers une
personnalité une incarnation qu'il avait
mis dans un dans un son ça a été une
inspiration quelque chose que tu avais
tu avais en tête ou pas du tout mais
maintenant que j'y pense c'est vrai
qu'il y a un lien
[Musique]
je pense que
le sujet mettre un nom et moi j'ai
vraiment j'ai une image d'un Patrick
mais je me suis dit mais en fait moi je
le vois comme ça mais moi j'ai des
Patrick qui sont des filles de 13 ans et
qui m'insulte ou qui disent des choses
hyper méchantes hyper gratuites parce
qu'en fait je pense pas que elle se rend
compte et c'est pas grave et j'ai des
mecs aussi de 15 de 20 de 30 enfin
n'importe en fait je pense que n'importe
qui peut se transformer en pas très
clair parce qu'en fait on se rend compte
que finalement c'est c'est intéressant
cette ce manque de civisme que on a en
Inco sur les réseaux sociaux à en
oublier qu'on se permettrait pas de
parler comme ça en vrai pourquoi en un
coup des gens se permettent d'être aussi
dur aussi blessants aussi cru
aussi rageux et pourquoi par écrit c'est
plus c'est tout à coup plus simple quoi
en vrai c'est mal je pense que l'élément
un des éléments principaux c'est mal
réaliser à quel point c'est ces
commentaires ou ces choses peuvent
heurter les gens et je sais que c'est un
peu basique déjà ça mais c'est le cas
c'est-à-dire que tous les gens qui je
parle de ce genre de sujets sont déjà
sortis heurté même par un petit
commentaire comme ça parce que bah ouais
même si en ligne même si quelqu'un qu'on
connaît pas ça peut nous ça peut toucher
quoi je crois qu'il y a aussi la
l'idée que bon en plus bah moi je suis
médiatisé là on peut donner notre
expérience en tant que personne qui a
notoriété mais il y a aussi ceux qui en
ont pas et qui sont pas enfin justement
j'ai une équipe de management j'ai les
moyens d'avoir une psy enfin je veux
dire je suis ultra protégée parce que
bon bah c'est sûr que la vie que j'ai
choisi elle est pas de tout repos mais
je pense aussi au harcèlement en ligne
sur des personnes vulnérables qui ont
pas cette chance là c'est là que je
trouve que ça devient super dangereux et
on en connaît plein des histoires de
jeunes surtout qui qui sont dans des
situations très très vulnérables et
c'est ça aussi que je voulais un peu
dénoncer c'était ce truc là de se dire
mais en fait
quand on dit quelque chose sur internet
non seulement ça reste mais en plus de
ça c'est au vu de tous donc c'est une
sorte de de bûcher en fait quoi sur
c'est humilié la personne publiquement
et voilà j'avais envie d'un peu abordé
tout ça en une personne c'était du coup
Patrick désolé pour tous les Patrick
dessus on passe à la question suivante
je te laisse appuyer une nouvelle fois
c'est un chronomètre derrière ce
chronomètre à chaque fois alors on va
courir un 100 m dans
un peu chiant je suis prête non non en
gros c'est un oui non alors d'ailleurs
dans ton dans ton premier album tu as
une chanson qui s'appelle oui ou non
tout à fait là en l'occurrence c'est un
oui ou non qu'on fait avec toutes les
personnes qui passent ici d'accord en
gros je vais te poser un maximum de
questions et je te laisse répondre le
plus possible par oui ou par non
d'accord aux questions qui viennent le
tout en une minute donc il y a peu de
questions l'idée c'est de répondre le
plus possible
tu te sens prête
un feet avec Jul est-ce que ce serait
possible oui tu pourrais te passer de
ton téléphone pendant 24 heures non la
trentaine ça te fait peur oui tu es à
l'aise dans les montagnes russes oui ça
t'arrive de dire 95 oui dual IPA elle
t'a appris des bons pas dedans oui tu
confirai ta chienne à Orelsan non
c'était pas chanteuse ce serait
psychologue oui tu aurais pu faire The
Voice ou la Star Academy non c'est le
meilleur acteur de sa génération oui il
y a des featurings que tu regrettes non
tu as déjà oublié tes paroles pendant un
concert oui Bruxelles c'est mieux que
Paris oui tu écoutes du métal non dans
un monde parfait est-ce qu’on ne mange
plus de viande oui la Belgique est-ce
qu'elle aurait dû gagner à Coupe du
Monde 2018 oui 2020 c'était la pire
année pour toi non tu as déjà triché
lors d'un examen oui et dernière
question pour terminer est-ce qu'il y a
tes propres chansons dans tes playlists
non c'est une question que je me suis
posée sur les pénis est-ce que genre si
tu es sur une plateforme de streaming
ils écoutent de la musique
si tu as ta propre chanson qui passe je
me suis mis en bloquer ah tu peux te
bloquer un artiste
et c'est même à l'aise un petit peu
bizarre voilà question que je me posais
un peu conne mais après après il y en a
qui le font
moi j'écoute énormément mes chansons
avant leur sortie et le jour où ça sort
plus jamais sauf pour des questions pro
mais je les écoute beaucoup beaucoup
pour mon imprégner parce que j'en suis
fière parce que je les aime parce que
c'est ça m'appartient encore
complètement
je t'invite à cliquer appuyer sur le
buzzer
c'est un téléphone on va voir si ce
cache derrière
c'est un temps d'écran c'est le mien en
l'occurrence sur une journée il y a
quelques jours beaucoup de temps sur les
réseaux sociaux je sais pas si tu l'as
activé ce truc de ouais moi je trouve
que ça c'est un bon chiffre
c'est pas mon pire chiffre ma moyenne
elle est plus élevée que ça la mienne
aussi justement
tu as une idée toi de ton temps d'écran
[Musique]
moments d'attente des moments de vide
c'est difficile de les créer quoi donc
ouais en fait on est tous addict surtout
et t'en parle dans Amour aimer danger
notamment toi tu te considères accro à
ton téléphone ah oui
oui je suis complètement accro à mon
téléphone comme beaucoup de gens et
depuis longtemps en fait Instagram pour
moi c'est un peu la maison quoi c'est là
où c'est comme ça que grandissent comme
ça je me suis fait connaître je connais
bien les gens je sais ce que les gens
vont aimer etc et après Tic-Toc c'est
n'importe quoi
et justement sortie
ton premier album TikTok était pas
encore vraiment là en restant au tout
début aujourd'hui ça a pris une grande
place y compris dans le domaine de la
musique tu as l'impression que ça a
changé quelque chose dans ta façon de
créer ou quand tu le vois avec des
d'autres artistes non mais je trouve que
ça a changé quelque chose dans la façon
dont tout autour tout s'articule parce
que je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
d'artistes qui sont un peu à la
recherche d'une traîne ou c'est
tellement énorme et en même temps moi
j'ai pris un peu de recul là dessus
parce que je me suis dit ben en fait
j'ai pas eu de Trend et avant
mais même sur le deuxième parce que je
sais pas pourquoi et pourtant ça va donc
en fait je pense que je préfère ça que
le contraire tu vois
faire de la musique
pour l'instant je trouve ça fasse
fascinant et presque un peu effrayant
parce que
punaise elle a encore plus vite c'est
encore plus puissant et un succès sur
Tik Tok le truc c'est qu'en plus pour
après le le transposer dans dans le réel
c'est c'est moi je me souviens déjà à
l'époque quand je faisais des vidéos sur
[ __ ] c'est horrible de dire allez à
l'époque en 2017
enfin je faisais les vidéos sur
Instagram sur facebook
c'était déjà dingue j'avais 4000 abonnés
c'est un truc de ouf parce que c'était
4000 personnes qui étaient à Bruxelles
et 4000 personnes à Bruxelles ça faisait
que chaque concert que je faisais dans
les bars il y avait des gens alors que
j'avais pas de la belle rien genre pas
d'album je faisais juste des consonnes
dans le débat c'était fou et c'est
peut-être déjà un phénomène aujourd'hui
4000 c'est un chiffre c'est c'est
dérisoire ça veut rien dire donc en fait
moi je trouve ça fou et je suis contente
vraiment contente d'avoir eu mon succès
et d'avoir eu cette place là sans TikTok
avant parce que je sais pas comment je
l'aurais géré et je sais pas si en fait
ça aurait marché pour moi sur Tik Tok
c'est d'autres Co
[Musique]
tendance à tout point de vue d'ascenseur
difficile donc ça a été une année très
difficile mais
c'était pas la pire c'était juste très
intense et
du coup je
cet album là il est à l'image aussi de
de ça d'une fin de tournée dans le début
de pandémie de du monde qui en un coup
est à l'arrêt qui en même temps enfin de
l'angoisse qui prend une place
considérable dans la vie de chacun et
puis de perte aussi quoi donc je pense
que cet album là il a été vachement
intime et il a été fait aussi dans des
conditions très intimes différentes du
fait ce temps là on va passer à au
dernier élément je t'invite à cliquer
une dernière fois sur le buzzer
on va voir sur quoi ça s'arrête
les photos appareil photo on va voir ce
qui se cache derrière je pense qu'il va
falloir deviner une gaufre c'était
peut-être trop facile en fait j'allais
dire est-ce que c'est une gaufre de
Bruxelles ou de Liège
le droit à une partie de Mario Kart nous
on a le droit à une dégustation si on
veut de gaufres qui viennent de l'île en
l'occurrence je vais te redonner le nom
si tu es si tu veux sachant qu'il y a
différents goûts exactement mais tu
connais
différents goûts donc tu prends ce que
tu veux mais
c'est la préférée du général de Gaulle
c'est bon marrant je sais pas ce que
c'est bon sucre comme toutes les autres
c'est bon mais je sais pas ce que c'est
vanille
il me dit que c'est vanille
tu en as eu deux parce que
le 6 décembre avec des spéculoos avec
des spéculoos et j'ai eu la madeleine de
Proust j'étais à la Saint-Nicolas
j'ai passé un excellent moment merci
beaucoup Hugo pour ce un grand plaisir
surtout que vraiment tu joues dans
quelques heures maintenant tu vas
sûrement faire tes balances mais courage
pour tout ça courage aussi pour la suite
de la tournée qui arrive
et donc la réédition qui est sortie la
semaine dernière c'était très cool merci
beaucoup pour ton temps merci à vous
aussi d'avoir suivi l'interview j'espère
que ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour découvrir les autres
interviews et puis sinon on se dit à
très vite pour d'autres formations sur
la chaîne salut à bientôt